Ich bin hier an einem Casting - nicht auf der Suche nach einem Job,
sondern auf der Suche nach dem Glück.
Das ist "Reporter Spezial", herzlich willkommen.
Es heisst ja, schöne Menschen seien attraktiv, erfolgreich,
vieles im Leben falle ihnen etwas leichter.
Wir wollen wissen: Macht Schönheit wirklich glücklich?
Die Antwort suche ich in dieser Sendung gemeinsam mit Menschen,
die sich z.T. extrem mit ihrem Aussehen
und ihrem Körper beschäftigen.
Wir sind in der Modelagentur Scout in Zürich.
Hier ist man ständig auf der Suche nach neuen Gesichtern.
Die jungen Frauen und Männer aus der ganzen Schweiz haben Hoffnung,
dass sie vielleicht schon bald für Gucci oder Calvin Klein
auf dem Laufsteg stehen.
Als erstes wird geprüft, ob die Masse stimmen.
Perfekt, 1,78 m, super Grösse.
Wer von ihnen schafft es wohl, einen Modelvertrag zu bekommen?
Wir möchten herausfinden: Was finden wir eigentlich schön?
Was macht Schönheit aus? Was findest du schön an dir?
An mir?
Ganz ehrlich: Ich finde das Schönste an mir meine Ausstrahlung,
weil sie sehr positiv ist.
Ich finde allgemein: Die Ausstrahlung macht Menschen schön.
Ich finde jeden Menschen auf seine eigene Art und Weise wunderschön.
Das ist super, das höre ich bei "Germany's Next Topmodel" immer.
Aber das stimmt nicht, sorry.
Ich habe auch eine tolle Ausstrahlung, bin 1,55 m,
dann hat man Chance, es stimmt einfach nicht.
Schöne Menschen müssen z.B. gross und dünn sein, oder?
Ja, das ist halt sozusagen der Standard.
Aber ich finde, jeder hat etwas Schönes an sich.
Das ist meine Meinung.
Warst du schon immer mit deinem Aussehen zufrieden?
Nein, das nicht. - Erzähl mal.
V.a. meine Grösse: "Ja, die Giraffe kommt wieder."
Das habe ich auch schon gehört: "Ah, die Giraffe kommt."
Oder: "Wieso musst du noch High Heels tragen, du bist gross genug."
Dann habe ich immer versucht, irgendwie so zu gehen,
weil ich "zu gross" war.
Aber irgendwann fand ich: "Es ist mir egal, ich liebe meine Grösse."
"Wenn es dir nicht passt - egal, dann bin ich halt die Giraffe."
Ist es bei dir ...
Du siehst nicht aus wie eine klassische Schönheit,
sage ich jetzt mal, z.B. deine Ohren.
Sagst du selbst: "Das ist total speziell."
Jetzt sage ich: Für mich ist es sehr speziell.
Früher habe ich das weniger behauptet.
Wie war es denn früher?
Früher wurde ich meist gemobbt, gehatet.
Auch wegen der Ohren, wegen des Charakters.
Wegen allem Möglichen wurde ich gemobbt.
Jetzt liebe ich mich, so wie ich bin.
Ich fotografiere erst dein Gesicht, du schaust mich ganz gerade an.
Gut.
Bettina Schaefer ist die Chefin der Agentur.
Das ehemalige Model entscheidet mit seinem Team,
mit welchem Gesicht, mit welchem Körper man versucht,
eine internationale Modelkarriere zu lancieren.
Wer es nicht schafft, kommt vielleicht immerhin
in die Kartei für Werbekunden - das sog. Commercial.
Darf ich dich kurz etwas fragen, Entschuldigung?- Ja.
Was siehst du jetzt an Leon?
Er hat einfach ...
Es gibt ganz typische Gesichter, auf die ich fliege, das ist Leon.
Er hat diese breiten Wangenknochen, diesen knutschroten Mund,
was einfach irrsinnig fotogen ist.
Er kann sich wirklich hinstellen, wie er will, er ist einfach fotogen.
Und er hat so dieses typische Kampagnengesicht.
Jetzt müsst ihr kurz Leon filmen.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Wenn du das hörst, wie ist das für dich?
Es ist schon ein Glü...
Es macht mich ...
Ich habe ja gelächelt.
Es macht einen schon glücklich, das zu hören.
V.a., wenn man es nicht so oft zu hören bekommt.
V.a. ich, mit meiner Vergangenheit. - Bei dir ist es anders?
Du hast nicht schon immer Komplimente bekommen?- Nein.
Sondern?
Früher in der Schule wurde ich auch gemobbt.
Wieso, muss man die fragen, ich weiss es selber nicht.
Wegen deines Aussehens? - Wegen meines Aussehens.
Das ist erstaunlich, denn dann stimmt der Vorwurf nicht,
dass wir als Gesellschaft immer das Gefühl haben,
Schönheitsideale würden von den Models vorgegeben.
Das stimmt gar nicht.
Im Alltag werden Menschen wie Leon eher fertiggemacht.
Ja, wenn sie jung sind.
Aber wer bestimmt dann, was wir schön finden?
Ich glaube schon, die grosse Masse.
D.h. aber nicht ...
Diese Gesichter, bei denen man denkt:
"Boah, ist der oder die schön!",
sind die Gesichter, die nicht fotogen sind.
Die sind schön und wenn man sie fotografiert,
sehen sie relativ langweilig aus, weil sie sehr harmonisch sind.
Es passt alles zueinander.
Aber sobald man zu grosse Lippen hat, rote Haare, zu viele freckles
oder ein breites Gesicht, das nicht so schön wirkt,
ist das das, was fotogen ist.
Fotogenität und Schönsein sind zwei Paar verschiedene Schuhe.
Noch mal den Mund auf, ein bisschen.
Und noch mal einen vollen smile, ja!
Ja. Kopf ein bisschen runter.
Egal, ob fotogen oder schön -
völlig aus dem Rahmen der Schönheitsnorm jung und schlank
fällt hier niemand. Die Forschung zeigt:
Es gibt menschliches Schönheitsempfinden für Symmetrie.
Aber v.a. die Gesellschaft macht das Schönheitsideal.
Wie stark prägt die eigene Oberfläche unser Leben?
Das will ich von Glücksforscher Mathias Binswanger wissen.
Landläufig heisst es ja, wahre Schönheit komme von innen.
Stimmt das gemäss Studien?
Das stimmt nicht, das ist eine Lüge für die, die nicht so gut aussehen.
In Wirklichkeit ist es so,
dass äussere Schönheit einen enormen Stellenwert hat
in unserer heutigen Gesellschaft.
Diesen muss man als solchen mal anerkennen.
Innere Schönheit - das sind andere Werte, die auch eine Rolle spielen.
Aber man kann einen Mangel an äusserer Schönheit
nicht mit innerer kompensieren. - Schönheit ist also extrem wichtig.
Welche Erkenntnisse hat man z.B. bezüglich Glück?
Dass natürlich Menschen, die schön sind,
ein unglaubliches Glück damit haben.
Denn sie haben etwas,
das in der heutigen Gesellschaft einen hohen Stellenwert hat.
Sie sind plötzlich begehrt,
haben Möglichkeiten, die andere nicht haben.
D.h., sie können z.T. schon mit relativ wenig Aufwand
sehr viel erreichen.
Das bringt Selbstbewusstsein, man denkt, man sei wirklich toll.
Aber es gibt ein Problem: Schönheit ist vergänglich.
Die Schönheit ist irgendwann wieder weg.
Dann merkt man: "Es lag gar nicht an mir, an meiner Person,
das war nur meine Schönheit."
Dann ist man nicht mehr so interessant.
Damit muss man auch leben.
Macht Schönheit erfolgreicher im Leben?
Ja, es gibt auch Studien dazu, dass Menschen, die schön sind,
tatsächlich auch mehr Erfolg haben,
dass man sie anderen Menschen vorzieht, die nicht so schön sind.
Auch aus diesem Grund zahlt es sich also aus, schön zu sein.
Bleib so. So bleiben.
Mach den Kopf ein bisschen tiefer.
Gutes Aussehen ist also ist also ein Kapital,
hat einen unumstrittenen Wert in unserer Leistungsgesellschaft.
Wir sind zurück beim Casting der Modelagentur Scout in Zürich.
Die 17-jährige Katrina Roelle aus St. Gallen
ist eine von neun jungen Menschen,
die sich Hoffnungen machen, mit ihrem Aussehen Geld zu verdienen.
Genau, damit ich ein anderes Foto habe.
Ich drücke alle Daumen.
Was ist Plan B, wenn es nicht funktioniert?
Wenn es nicht funktioniert ... Ja, gut.
Ich hatte die Chance, dafür bin ich dankbar.
Ich finde es ultracool, dass ich hier sein konnte.
Wenn es nicht weitergeht, geht das allgemeine Leben weiter:
Abschluss, Studium und so.
Hast du ein gutes Gefühl? Bekommst du einen Vertrag?
Ich würde es hoffen, ja. Ich glaube immer daran.
Wenn es nicht klappt, mache ich weiter,
bis sich mir irgendwo eine Tür öffnet.
Aber dann wirst du ja immer enttäuscht.
Du müsstest dir doch etwas suchen, das vielleicht funktioniert.
Ich finde, man soll an seine Ziele glauben und weitermachen wie bisher.
Einfach daran glauben, dass du es schaffst.
Jeder kann es schaffen ... - Dafür kämpfen. Ja.
Man muss nur den Mut dazu haben.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr gekommen seid. Super.
Nach 2 Std. ist das Probe-Shooting vorbei,
die Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten werden entlassen.
Ob sie es geschafft haben, wissen sie noch nicht.
Wir hingegen dürfen beim Moment der Entscheidung dabei sein.
Es ist mehr für uns, um zu wissen, was fürs Booking drinliegt.
Mich würde jetzt noch mal ...
... die mit den abstehenden Ohren interessieren.
Larissa. - Also ...
Die wird auf jeden Fall kein klassisches Model.
Aber das Gesicht finde ich total cool.- Mega.
So hübsch-hässlich ist sie.
Auch sie wurde während der ganzen Schulzeit ausgelacht und gemobbt.
Der Klassiker. - Wie passt das zusammen,
dass ihr sagt, sie sei total cool, aber unsere Gesellschaft sagt,
sie lache man aus, sie sei hässlich.
Das Andere ist eben genauso toll.
Man hört vielleicht immer nur eine Seite, aber es gibt mehrere Seiten.
Der Mensch ist so unterschiedlich: grösser, kleiner, breiter, schmaler.
Die Persönlichkeit dahinter macht den Ausdruck komplett.
Eine schöne Fassade allein ist langweilig.
Eben, das ist wunderschön, das ist so ...
Also das ist natürlich ... Geh noch mal zurück.
Da könntest du jetzt "Gucci" drüberschreiben.
Das Gesicht bleibt einem. - Ja, das stimmt, total.
Ich möchte gern Leon anschauen.
Mit den leichten Sommersprossen. - Er ist ja noch sehr jung.
Aber man sieht es z.B. hier:
Er hat ein unglaublich fotogenes Gesicht.
Sind alle damit einverstanden, dass er toll ist.- Ja.
Das sehen wir auf den ersten Blick.
Er hat ein Gesicht wie modelliert, ist fotogen - also ausser Thema.
Ah, wen haben wir denn da?
Das bin ich, bitte schnell weiter! - Nein!
Die hat auch etwas, muss ich echt sagen.
In welche Kategorie käme ich? - Commercial.
Und ich kann sagen, ein gut laufender Commercial.
Was für ein interessantes Gesicht. Come on!
Für "eigentlich nicht zu brauchen" ist "interessant" das Wort.
Du hast für mich ein sehr attraktives Gesicht.
Wunderschöne Augen und sehr ansprechend.
Eine mega Ausstrahlung. - Ja.
Vielen Dank. - Das weisst du ja auch.
Schau mal!
Das ist Katrina. - Katrina, ja.
Sie ist eigentlich so ...
Sie ist eigentlich das typische, klassische Model.
Aber das brauchen wir ja auch. - Die ist toll.
Jetzt würde ich gern noch mal ...
Was ist hier das Fazit? - Ja, perfekt, top.- Top.
Also sie bekommt ...
Ja, die wird ... - Die wird gebucht?
Wie viele habt ihr jetzt insgesamt, bei denen ihr sicher seid,
dass ihr sie unter Vertrag nehmen wollt, von heute?
Modelmässig unter Vertrag ganz definitiv zwei.
Und zwei, drei für Commercial,
bei denen wir sagen, doch, werbemässig ...
Das ist auch ein knallhartes Business,
auch wie ihr jetzt kommentiert habt.
Einer sieht bäuerisch aus, der andere ist zu breit,
bei der dritten stimmen die Proportionen nicht.
Sehr menschenfreundlich ist das nicht.
Am Schluss ist das, was verkauft, gut und der Rest ...
Ja.
Aber bei einem Bürojob wirst du knallhart bewertet,
wie gut du im Tippen bist
oder wenn du Mediziner bist,
wirst du auch nur beurteilt, wie gut du bist, z.B. als Chirurg.
Das ist ja in jeder Branche so.
Macht dich Schönheit glücklich in deinem Leben?- Nö.
Nö? - Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ich glaube, das hat auch damit zu tun,
dass ich so lange damit konfrontiert bin.
Natürlich fand ich das auch geil, als ich angefangen habe zu modeln.
Aber wenn du drin bist, siehst du die Schönheit nicht mehr.
Wenn du meine Freundin bist,
sehe ich deine schönen Augen irgendwann auch nicht mehr.
Dann interessieren mich deine inneren Werte.
Deswegen sehe ich das nicht mehr. - Vielen Dank, Bettina.
Wir sind gespannt, wie es mit den jungen Menschen weitergeht,
die wir heute kennengelernt habe.
Bei uns geht es jetzt weiter mit Menschen,
die auch ständig auf ihr Äusseres angesprochen werden,
aber im Gegensatz zu ihnen hier nicht unbedingt positiv.
Menschen, die dem "Schönheitsideal" des schlanken Körpers
nicht entsprechen.
Was sie erleben, sehen wir jetzt.
Hochstossen, das geht alles einfach, und das Becken hochschieben.
Das Becken hochschieben, hoch, hoch, noch etwas.
Alexandra Baumann beim Training mit ihrem Personal Coach.
Langsam wieder zurück.
Stufe 1-10?
35.
Die Standardantwort.
Bei 1 schläft ihr das Gesicht ein
und bei 10 stirbt sie.
D.h., wenn sie mir sagt, sie sei auf 9, beginne ich aufzupassen.
Aber Alexandra ist mittlerweile so clever,
dass sie relativ schnell sagt, sie sei auf 9.
Aber jeder Kunde ist etwas anders.
Der eine fällt schon fast um, wenn er sagt, er sei bei 7.
Wenn Alexandra sagt, sie sei auf 35, können wir noch einen machen.
Hoch, hoch, hoch, genau. Langsam hinunter.
Erst wenn das Gesäss hinten ist, kannst du absitzen.
Das Gesäss nach hinten bringen. Ja. Go! Machen wir noch einen, nicht?
Das war ein Ja.
Du hast Glück, dass Leute hier sind, sonst würdest du etwas hören.
Sicher? Ich bin es gewohnt, du darfst auch so.
Du kannst hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch.
Gut. Langsam zurück.
Absitzen, ausschütteln.
In solchen Momenten würde ich ihn gern verschenken und abgeben
und die Kontaktdaten löschen.
Aber eben, wir machen alles freiwillig.
Die 41-Jährige kämpft mit Übergewicht.
Seit Kurzem ist sie erstmals zuversichtlich,
dass ihr jahrelanges Leiden unter dem Körpergewicht
ein Ende haben könnte - dank einer Magenbypass-Operation.
In erster Linie bedeutet es Freiheit,
die ich mir langsam zurückerobere,
nachdem ich mich in meinem Körper sehr lange wie gefangen fühlte.
Wir haben genau diese Übungen oder Variationen davon
mit noch fast 140 kg gemacht.
Das war eine etwas andere Nummer. - Definitiv.
... bis du wieder in der Plank bist.
Die Fersen heben, das Gewicht nach vorne geben.
Noch etwas wandern mit den Händen. Sauber, schön, gut.
Den eigenen Körper als unendlich schwere Last empfinden
und ihn ablehnen -
dieses Gefühl entwickelte sich bei Alexandra Baumann schon sehr früh.
Bereits als Mädchen wurde sie auf ihr Gewicht reduziert.
Wenn ich Kinderfotos von mir anschaue
und mich mit anderen Kindern auf den Fotos vergleiche,
habe ich nicht das Gefühl, ich sei damals schon viel zu schwer gewesen.
Aber ich weiss, dass es genau das Alter war,
in dem die ersten Hänseleien anfingen.
Man nannte mich "Tonne", "fette Kuh".
Nachdem mir zum ersten Mal ein Nachbarsjunge sagte:
"Du bist eine richtig eklige fette Tonne",
konnte ich mich selbst nie mehr anders wahrnehmen als so.
Wenn ich versuche, mich an meine Kindheit,
meine Jugend, meine frühen Erwachsenenjahre zu erinnern,
welche Momente es gab, in denen ich mich schön fühlte ...
Es sind vielleicht drei oder vier, die mir so spontan einfallen.
Wenn ich aufzählen müsste,
in wie vielen Momenten ich mich eklig, abstossend, unzufrieden ...
Wir hätten Hunderte zur Auswahl, die ich aufzählen könnte.
Negative Emotionen habe sie jeweils mit Essen runtergeschluckt,
sagt Baumann.
Sie wurde zur Frustesserin.
Mittlerweile ist sie mehr als 30 kg leichter,
doch trotzdem übergewichtig.
Die Gesellschaft lässt sie das gnadenlos spüren.
Einkaufen und auswärts essen sind zwei Dinge,
die für mich sehr oft ein Spiessrutenlauf werden.
Weil ich das Gefühl habe oder oft das Gefühl hatte,
ich könnte gar nicht gewinnen.
Denn wenn ich etwas Gesundes einkaufe
oder im Restaurant etwas Gesundes esse,
höre ich sehr oft:
"Ja, klar, jetzt isst sie einen Salat,
aber kaum ist sie zu Hause, gibt es Schokolade."
Wenn ich etwas Ungesundes einkaufe ...
Kurz nach der Magenbypass-Operation ist mir z.B. Folgendes passiert:
Ich habe einige Protein-Puddings eingekauft.
Ein älterer Herr hat mich von oben bis unten betrachtet und gesagt:
"Friss doch noch mehr Pudding, dann wirst du noch hässlicher."
Oder ich hatte mal einen Chef, der zu mir gesagt hat:
"Kurze Hosen möchte ich an dir wirklich nicht sehen,
es ekelt mich, wenn ich deine Beine anschauen muss."
So. Er war selbst übergewichtig. Heute würde ich anders reagieren.
Damals war ich so schockiert, dass ich nichts mehr sagen konnte.
Ich finde auch bei Männern ...
Es ist noch mal anders.
Wenn ein Mann ein bisschen übergewichtig ist,
ist er eher gemütlich oder so.
Ich glaube, bei Männern ist es noch mal anders.
Ich habe schon das Gefühl,
dicke Frauen triggern extrem in der Gesellschaft.
Es ist die schlechteste Variante dessen, was man sein kann.
* Wabernde Musik *
Ruth Dürrenmatt, 69 Jahre alt.
Auch sie hat eine Magenbypass-Operation hinter sich.
Das übermässige Essen bekam sie nie in den Griff.
Ich kenne Menschen, die ein Stück Schokolade essen.
Man kann süchtig nach Schokolade sein, nach Zucker.
Sie nehmen ein Stückchen, lassen es auf der Zunge und sind zufrieden.
Ich könnte kein Stückchen Schokolade nehmen,
dann fresse ich gleich die ganze Tafel.
* Vereinzelte Geigentöne *
Ruth Dürrenmatt ist Künstlerin und die jüngste Tochter
des Schriftstellers Friedrich Dürrenmatt.
Ihr Aussehen, insbesondere ihr Gewicht,
seien immer Thema gewesen in ihrem Leben.
Auch in der Familie.
Mein eigener Vater nannte mich Trampel und stauchte mich zusammen.
Darunter habe ich natürlich schon gelitten.
Aber wenn er halt findet, ich sei ein Trampel, dann bitte schön.
Dann sah ich ihn jeweils an und dachte: "Ja, ja, typisch Mann."
Frauen kritisieren, weil sie ein paar Pfunde zu viel haben,
aber was ist mit Ihrem Ranzen, Herr Dürrenmatt?
Ich habe jahrelang geglaubt ...
... darunter gelitten, dass ich nicht die schönste Frau bin.
Aber ...
Eines Tages habe ich einfach gemerkt, dass das Humbug ist.
Es ist mir egal, was die Gesellschaft denkt.
Denn sie liegt falsch, fertig, Punkt.
Mit ihrem Aussehen sei sie während Jahren angeeckt,
habe als gelernte Opernsängerin immer wieder Bühnenjobs nicht erhalten
mit der Begründung, ihre Figur sei unpassend.
Schliesslich verabschiedete sich Dürrenmatt vom Zwang,
äusseren Schönheitskriterien genügen zu müssen.
Sie liess sich zur Illustratorin und Grafikerin umschulen.
Die Augen geöffnet punkto Schönheit habe ihr ein Schicksalsschlag.
Mein Onkel war wie ein zweiter Vater für mich.
Ich habe ihn in den Tod begleitet.
Und für mich war er wunderschön, bis zuletzt.
Denn er hatte eine Schönheit in seiner Seele,
die ich gesehen habe und die einzigartig war.
Und das ist wahre Schönheit.
Seien wir mal ehrlich, ich könnte es so vergleichen:
Es gibt wunderschön präsentierte Schachteln,
in denen es wunderbare Schokolade geben soll.
Dann öffnet man die Schachtel,
man freut sich über die schöne Schachtel,
öffnet sie und es kommen Würmer heraus
oder irgendetwas oder die Schokolade sieht aus wie eine Pfütze aus Kot.
Entschuldigung, aber dann nützt die schöne Schachtel nichts.
Über 60 kg leichter ist Ruth Dürrenmatt seit ihrer Operation.
Schönheit war kein Beweggrund für den Eingriff.
Von einem schlanken Körper träumt sie schon lange nicht mehr.
Ich spüre nicht, dass mein Glück
von meiner Figur oder meiner Schönheit abhängt.
Sondern im Moment.
Ich fühle Dankbarkeit.
Denn jetzt kann ich besser gehen.
Ich fühle Dankbarkeit, weil es leichter ist.
Ich kann jetzt in der Küche für mich kochen.
Und am Morgen kann ich staubsaugen
und das Bett machen
und ich bin glücklich darüber, dass ich das jetzt kann.
Denn für sehr lange konnte ich das nicht so.
Das war eine Qual.
Alexandra Baumann auf dem Weg zu einem Arzttermin.
Stark übergewichtige, adipöse Menschen wie sie,
die während langer Zeit erfolglos versucht haben,
ihr Gewicht zu reduzieren, gelten offiziell als krank.
Sie haben Fettsucht.
Ihr BMI liegt weit über dem von Normalgewichtigen,
viele sind sozial isoliert.
Schön fühlen sich die wenigsten von ihnen.
Trotzdem versucht der Viszeralchirurg Marco Bueter
im Zusammenhang mit einer Magenbypass-Operation
die Schönheitsdiskussion möglichst zu vermeiden.
Denn er stellt fest: Die Meinung sei hartnäckig verbreitet,
dass es sich bei krankhaftem Übergewicht
nicht um ein Gesundheitsproblem,
sondern um einen selbst verschuldeten Schönheitsfehler handle.
Wir versuchen, Patienten gesünder zu machen,
im Alltag funktioneller zu machen.
Das ist auch etwas, das wir unseren Kollegen,
vielen Zuweisern immer wieder erklären müssen, den Skeptikern:
dass es nicht darum geht, jemanden schöner zu machen,
dünner zu machen,
sondern es geht nur darum, ihn gesünder zu machen.
Und daran lasse ich mich auch messen.
Was ist mit den Begleiterkrankungen, Blutzucker, Bluthochdruck?
Was ist mit der Lebensqualität, was ist mit der Mutter,
die plötzlich nach dem Gewichtsverlust
wieder mit ihren Kindern spielen kann?
Das sind Aspekte, die mir wichtig sind.
Aber keine kosmetischen Aspekte.
Und die stehen bei dieser Operation auch nicht im Vordergrund.
Bueter stellt bei seiner Arbeit immer wieder fest,
dass Hausärzte Patienten nicht zuweisen,
obwohl die Kriterien für eine Operation erfüllt sind.
Er spricht von Diskriminierung.
Dass die Kollegen das nicht zuweisen, kann zwei Gründe haben:
entweder kennen sie die Daten einfach nicht
bzw. erkennen sie sie nicht an, das kann ja sein.
Oder sie haben ein emotionales Problem damit,
die Patienten zuzuweisen, weil sie immer noch davon ausgehen,
dass Adipositas keine Erkrankung ist,
sondern ein mehr oder weniger selbst bestimmbares Schicksal,
das man mit ein bisschen Sport, Diät und Selbstdisziplin
ganz leicht in den Griff bekommt.
Und das ist falsch, diese Daten gibt es einfach nicht.
Wer das glaubt,
hat zehn, 15 Jahre medizinische wissenschaftliche Entwicklung
schlicht verpennt.
Diskriminierung gegen Dicke:
Ist das gesellschaftlich einfach so akzeptiert,
weil landläufig gilt, Dicksein ist hässlich und selbstverschuldet?
Alexandra Baumann hält dagegen und zeigt sich.
Nicht schlank will sie werden, sondern akzeptiert, wie sie ist.
Es ist mir manchmal auch wichtig,
auf einer Plattform wie z.B. Instagram
einfach mal einen unperfekten Körper zu zeigen.
Etwas, das noch in Arbeit ist, zu zeigen.
Und etwas, das einfach dem Schema,
das sonst auf der Plattform unterwegs ist, nicht entspricht.
Mir ist es extrem wichtig, authentisch zu bleiben,
mit allem, was dazugehört.
Und das sind halt manchmal auch etwas unschöne Momente.
Alexandra Baumann ist jetzt bei mir.
Alexandra Baumann, als ich diesen Beitrag gesehen habe,
habe ich vieles von dem, was ich gehört habe, nicht geglaubt.
Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass wir wirklich so krass sind
und Menschen so hart nach ihrem Aussehen beurteilen.
Ich erlebe es einfach immer wieder.
Manchmal deutlich, manchmal ins Gesicht gesagt,
manchmal auch so, dass die Leute es gerade laut genug sagen,
dass ich es höre.
Aber ich denke, ich werde an jedem Tag,
an dem ich lebe und schon gelebt habe,
wegen meines Äusseren in eine Schublade gesteckt.
Das nehme ich schon so wahr.
Würdest du sagen, das hat dein Leben unglücklich gemacht?
Ich weiss nicht, ob unglücklich der richtige Ausdruck ist.
Es hat mein Leben wahrscheinlich nicht einfach gemacht.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl, mehr leisten zu müssen als andere,
damit mich die Menschen auch akzeptieren.
Aber natürlich gab es Ablehnungsmomente,
was mich dann unglücklich gemacht hat.
Was ist es denn, was man in dich oder Menschen wie dich hineinprojiziert,
bei denen man irgendwie findet ...
Ich glaube, es ist zum grossen Teil eine Schuldfrage.
Man bekommt von der Gesellschaft
eine Schuld am Übergewicht zugewiesen.
Und es ist eine Disziplinfrage.
In mich wird hineinprojiziert, dass ich keine Disziplin habe,
keinen Willen habe, mir keine Mühe gegeben habe,
dass ich mit einer Magenverkleinerungsoperation
möglicherweise einen einfachen Weg genommen habe.
Seit ich 13 war, versuche ich ja abzunehmen.
Was ja alles schon passiert ist und was ich alles schon versucht habe,
wird von sehr vielen weder verstanden noch gewürdigt.
Und es wird auch nicht nachgefragt, sondern die Schublade geht auf:
"willenloser Mensch, macht keinen Sport,
sitzt den ganzen Tag vor dem Fernseher und isst."
Und was war der Grund? Warum hast du es nicht geschafft, abzunehmen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es  e i n e n  Grund gibt,
warum ich es nicht geschafft habe.
Ich habe es immer wieder versucht, mit ganz verschiedenen Ansätzen.
Ich habe auch immer wieder abgenommen,
ich konnte es einfach nicht halten.
Irgendwann kam auch der ganze Jo-Jo-Effekt hinzu.
Dass es fast noch weiter stieg? - Ja.
Irgendwann musste ich einfach anerkennen, dass es etwas ist ...
Für mich persönlich ist es eine Suchterkrankung.
Ich habe Esssucht.
Die ist immer noch da.
Und ich merke, dass ich auch auf einer anderen Ebene
weiter daran arbeiten muss.
Du wirst also nicht plötzlich glücklicher,
nur weil du 35 kg abgenommen hast.
Man wird schon glücklicher und das Leben wird auch einfacher,
aber die Dämonen, die man hat, die psychischen Probleme,
die soziale Isolation,
die Einsamkeitsgefühle oder was auch immer ...
So viele Gefühle brachten mich zum Essen,
manchmal auch positive Gefühle, abgesehen davon.
Diese sind immer noch genau gleich da.
Ich glaube, die Aufgabe besteht darin,
einen Umgang mit diesen Gefühlen zu lernen.
Was ich schon immer hatte:
Ich hatte schon immer eine sehr starke Disziplin.
In fast allem.
Ich habe alle Prüfungen in meinem Leben geschafft,
wenn ich mir etwas vorgenommen habe, habe ich es durchgezogen.
Und beim Übergewicht ging es einfach nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund,
warum man allergisch darauf reagiert,
wenn einem jemand an den Kopf wirft: "Du versuchst es ja gar nicht."
Dann denke ich:
"Du hast keine Ahnung, was ich schon alles probiert habe."
Es besteht auch ein ziemlicher Leidensdruck,
weil das Übergewicht halt etwas sehr Augenfälliges ist.
Du kannst es fast nicht verstecken, im Gegensatz zu anderen ...
Es gibt andere Suchterkrankungen, mit denen man
relativ gut funktionieren kann, ohne dass es je irgendjemand merkt.
Bei der Esssucht ist das einfach anders.
Wenn wir von "Abweichung vom Schönheitsideal" reden -
hast du das Gefühl, dass Menschen, die übergewichtig sind,
härter kritisiert werden als jemand,
der vielleicht kein perfektes Gesicht oder Pigmentstörungen oder so hat?
Reagiert man auf Menschen mit Übergewicht anders?
Ich habe natürlich eine gefilterte Wahrnehmung,
als jemand, der das Leben lang Übergewicht hatte.
Aber es ist schon meine Erfahrung, ja.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist etwas, das viele Menschen einfach abstösst.
Also wirklich körperlicher Ekel? - Ja.
Oder man muss sich auch anhören, alle Dicken seien ungepflegt.
Und ich denke so ...
Das stimmt genauso wenig wie dass ... Ich weiss auch nicht.
Man kann so viele Klischees bringen.
Ich denke, das ist ein wenig ...
Die Leute ziehen den Schluss, die Person lasse sich gehen.
Aber das muss ja gar nicht so sein. Das ist schon etwas, das ich ...
Ich habe schon das Gefühl,
dass mit Übergewichtigen hart ins Gericht gegangen wird.
Du hast es gesagt: Wir sind sehr stark von Oberflächen inspiriert,
beeinflusst - eine ziemlich oberflächliche Gesellschaft.
Ich glaube, das stimmt zu einem gewissen Grad.
Interessant ist ja:
Wenn wir von Schönheit reden, denken wir immer an Aussehen.
Aber es gibt Menschen, wenn man mit denen über Schönheit spricht,
denken sie an etwas anderes.
Eine von ihnen sitzt dort drüben und zu ihr gehen wir jetzt.
Hier sitzt - herzlich willkommen - Zina Indermaur.
Seit du vier warst, bist du blind, Zina.
Deshalb hat Schönheit für dich eine ganz andere Bedeutung
als für uns Sehende.
Was heisst schön, in Bezug auf Menschen, für dich?
Wenn ich jemandem begegne,
ist es in erster Linie tatsächlich der Geruch in den ersten 10-30 Sek.
Riecht der gut? "Oh nein", "na ja" oder ja.
Dann ist es die Stimme, also übers Gehör.
Und wenn es um ein längeres Gespräch geht,
ist es wie bei so vielen der Charakter
oder der Inhalt des Gesprächs, was dabei herauskommt,
das, was ich schön finde.
Wie nimmst du jemanden wahr?
Du hast vorhin schon mit Alexandra gesprochen, mit mir auch.
Wie hast du Alexandra wahrgenommen? Wie würdest du sie beschreiben?
Das ist sehr schwierig.
Während der Corona-Zeit ist es so,
dass, wenn man sich nicht berühren kann ...
Ein zusätzlicher Faktor zum Hören und dem Geruchssinn
ist auch das Spüren, der Tastsinn.
Würdest du sie sonst berühren? - Ja, beim Begrüssen oder Einhängen.
So kann ich schon viel von der Person aufnehmen.
Das entfällt jetzt.
Aber ich weiss, dass sie grösser ist als ich.
Die Stimme kommt von etwas weiter oben.
Aber ja ...
Wie würdest du dich Zina beschreiben?
Ui.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich denke, ich würde bei den äusserlichen Faktoren ...
Ich würde mal sagen, wie klein ich bin, ich bin 1,60 m.
Wahrscheinlich dass ich braune Locken habe, braune Augen.
Und dann würde wohl ziemlich bald schon kommen,
dass ich mich als füllig, übergewichtig, mit Kurven ...
Ich selbst würde all das schon beschreiben.
Dass ich nicht ... Übergewichtig, wie man es nennen will.
Das ist sicher etwas, das ich sehr schnell über mich sage.
Obwohl es mich immer nervt, wenn es andere tun.
Weil ich immer denke: Es gibt andere Wörter,
mit denen man mich beschreiben könnte,
als nur gerade "die Dicke in der Ecke".
Zina, erstaunt dich etwas davon,
wie Alexandra sich jetzt beschrieben hat?
Ja ... das Übergewicht.
Der Rest ... Also die 1,60 m hätte ich selbst auch gesagt.
Und ...
Wieso erstaunt dich das Übergewicht?
Weil sie nicht dick klingt.
Nicht behäbig oder so.
Du hast also eine Vorstellung davon,
wie ein übergewichtiger Mensch klingen müsste?- Nein.
Nein, aber es hat oft auch mit dem Atem zu tun - vielleicht.
Man tut den Menschen dann unrecht mit dem schleppenden Reden,
mit dem Bewegen des Körperapparats.
* Sie atmet schwer aus. * Etwa so.
Weil es anstrengend ist. - Ja, evtl.
Das hört man und entsprechend klingt alles etwas angestrengter.
Dann denkt man, in deren Kopf klingt es wohl auch so.
Würdest du dir manchmal wünschen, wir alle wären etwas blinder,
wenn ich das so sagen darf,
und etwas weniger aufs Aussehen fokussiert?
Ich finde es problematisch, zu sagen, wir wären alle blinder.
Vielleicht, wenn ich es ...
Ich verwende gern den Ausdruck "hinter eine Fassade blicken".
Das würde ich mir wünschen. - Das ist eigentlich das Gegenteil.
Das ist nicht weniger, sondern mehr wahrnehmen.
Ja, das würde ich mir wünschen.
Denn ich finde es ja auch schön, wenn man wahrgenommen wird.
Das kann ja auch etwas sehr Positives sein.
Kann.
Ist es nicht immer, aber es kann.
Schönheit ist nichts, das man geschenkt bekommt und dann hat,
sondern in unserer Gesellschaft ist gutes Aussehen auch etwas,
wofür man viel tun kann oder auch tun muss.
Wir wollen wissen, wie es jenen Menschen geht,
die mein Reporterkollege Hanspeter Bäni
vor ein paar Jahren begleitet hat
für seinen "DOK"-Film "Mein Körper - mein Werk".
Menschen, die sehr viel tun für ihren Körper,
die pumpen, trainieren und ihn formen.
Miguel Bieger vor fünf Jahren.
Es ist einfach meine Leidenschaft.
Ich mache es gern und präsentiere es gern.
Aber ich tue es auch fürs Wohlbefinden und Glücklichsein.
Beim 21-Jährigen drehte sich damals alles ums Bodybuilding.
Er hatte zahlreiche Fitnessabos und trainierte täglich.
Bieger war auf dem besten Weg dazu, in diesem Sport Karriere zu machen.
Hier in meinem Zimmer habe ich ein Bild
der Schweizermeisterschaft vom letzten Jahr.
Ich habe die Herbst- und die Schweizermeisterschaft
im Junioren-Bodybuilding gewonnen.
Das war mein erster Wettkampf und ein ziemlicher Erfolg für mich.
Biegers damalige Freundin war ebenfalls Bodybuilderin.
Auch sie nahm an Wettkämpfen teil.
Ja, sehr gut, den linken Arm noch etwas nach oben.
Genau.
Noch mal eine Vierteldrehung.
Passt, schön, ja.
Tipptopp.
Heute ist bei Miguel Bieger fast alles anders.
Sein einstiges Leben scheint weit weg zu sein.
Auch hat er eine andere Freundin.
Bei mir kam es ganz klar so:
Ich war auf Reisen, drei Monate, allein.
Ich bin von zu Hause ausgezogen, mit der Ex-Freundin war Schluss.
Und, äh ...
Ja, ich habe mich dort selbst gefunden.
Ich habe den Lifestyle nicht mehr so verfolgt, nicht mehr so gelebt.
Es hat mir abgelöscht, die Motivation hat gefehlt.
Ich habe einen neuen Weg eingeschlagen.
Aber auch jetzt ist die Schönheit nicht vergessen.
Man schaut ja trotzdem noch auf sich.
Man hat nur einen Körper und der ist immer wichtig.
Aber das Sixpack ist nicht mehr so wichtig.
Sonst hätte ich ja hier ...
Jetzt habe ich einen Wohlstandsbauch, kein Sixpack mehr.
Da sieht man, dass der Fokus nicht mehr bei der Fitness liegt.
Biegers Geschichte hört sich an wie die Banalität des grossen Bruchs:
Anstatt ins Training
stecke er seine Energie jetzt halt in sein Malergeschäft.
Ist gut? - Tipptopp.
Ja. - Ich warte, dass es trocknet.
Vielleicht noch ein Tropfen Schwarz rein, dann ist es tipptopp.
Also passt der Farbton? - Passt gut, ja.
Sieht gut aus. - Vielleicht noch etwas Schwarz.
Nein, das sollte passen, das können wir so lassen.
Super, sehr gut gemacht.
Sein Leben sei schon sehr anders als früher, sagt er.
V.a. etwas habe er gewonnen: Freiheit.
Beim Fitness musste man immer gehen,
musste immer machen, was am Besten ist.
Oder ein Trainer hat es sogar vorgeschrieben.
So konnte ich nie unabhängig sein.
Ich musste immer einen strikten Plan verfolgen.
Alessandro Stambene.
Auch er war vor fünf Jahren beinah täglich im Fitnesscenter anzutreffen.
Wie wichtig ist der Körperkult heute unter den Jungen?
Ich denke, heutzutage ist das sehr viel wichtiger als früher.
Man möchte ja erstens gegeneinander, untereinander bei den Männern
möglichst fit sein, weil eine riesige Konkurrenz herrscht.
Und man möchte natürlich auch bei den Frauen sehr gut ankommen.
Die Frauen sind ja heutzutage auch in dieser ganzen Fitnessszene.
Man möchte nicht schlecht dastehen neben den Frauen,
wenn man sieht: Die schafft ja mehr als ich.
Ernährung und Fitness waren die zentralen Themen
im Leben des ehemaligen Fussballers Stambene.
* Stöhnen *
Selbst bei Ferien im Ausland überliess er nichts dem Zufall.
Ich habe selbst eine Tasche nur mit Essen mitgenommen.
Ich musste einige Dosen mitnehmen, Büchsen-Food.
Hier haben wir Kichererbsen.
Davon habe ich gleich ein paar. - Warum denn?
Das gibt es doch hier auch.
Man findet leider nicht immer alles. Ich gehe lieber auf Nummer sicher.
Ich möchte immer eine Lösung für mich finden,
um meinen Körper immer optimal zu versorgen.
An Ernährungs- und Fitnessplänen
feilte er damals in seinem Kinderzimmer stundenlang.
Nicht nur für sich.
Ich habe mittlerweile über 100 Athleten,
denen ich mit meiner Erfahrung
so gut wie möglich zu helfen versuche.
Alessandro Stambene im Sommer 2020.
Er hat seinen Traum in einem Soussol in Schlieren verwirklicht.
Für den Laien ein banaler Keller mit Fitnessgeräten -
für ihn weit mehr.
Wir sind hier auf dem Athleten-Stützpunkt,
unserem sog. Underground Gym.
Es ermöglicht uns, mit den Menschen
eine persönliche Atmosphäre zu haben.
Ich bereite gerade das Training vor,
um nachher mit den Leuten Vollgas zu geben.
Hey, bello, ciao! - Wie geht's dir?
Gut und dir? Fit und munter? - Auch gut.
Heute geben wir wieder Gas, super. - Ja, ich muss.
Gehen wir, komm! Schön, dai!
Ilir Bajrami, einer seiner rund 100 Kunden, die er persönlich coacht.
Stark, super. Okay. Wir haben noch zwei Übungen.
70 % seiner Kunden seien Leute, die abnehmen und Muskeln aufbauen wollen.
Beleg dafür ist die sog. Transformationswand.
Unser Hauptziel ist, Dynamik in die Menschen zu bringen,
eine positive Lebensveränderung beeinflussen zu können.
Gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm!
3'500 Fr. hat Bajrami für drei Monate Fitnesscoaching bezahlt.
Für den 23-Jährigen ging die Rechnung auf.
Es hing einfach alles runter, es war nicht schön.
Die Hemden wurden immer enger.
Das Gesamtpaket stimmte einfach nicht mehr.
Für mich war immer alles schwerer.
Beim Sport, wenn man mit Kollegen Fussball spielen oder joggen geht,
war man immer der Letzte.
Mittlerweile bin ich jeweils der Erste.
Kunden wie Bajrami sind die beste Werbung
für Stambene und sein Fitnesskonzept.
Machbar aber nicht einfach soll es bei ihm sein.
Es geht nur mit Willen, Disziplin und Arbeit.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Daher ist der Körper ein Stück weit das Spiegelbild eines Charakters.
Das spielt schon auch mit hinein.
Einer, komm! Bleiben, bleiben, bleiben, dai!
Physische und psychische Veränderung, das fasziniert Stambene nach wie vor.
Ein gutes Körpergefühl bedeute Schönheit und befriedige.
Davon kann er jetzt leben.
Ihr habt mich schon vor fünf Jahren im Zimmer gefilmt,
wie ich in meinem kleinen Büro war.
Damals war das noch lustig.
Jetzt, nach fünf Jahren, sagen die Leute, die gelacht haben:
"Fuck, der Typ verdient jetzt Geld, ohne dass er arbeiten muss."
"Er tut, was er gern tut."
Ich ziehe weiter durch, was ich vor fünf Jahren gemacht habe.
Ich möchte auf jeden Fall noch mehr erreichen.
Stambenes Zukunftsvision: mehr Fitnesscenter, eine Kochlinie,
und am liebsten noch mit 80 Jahren in seinem Underground Gym anzutreffen.
Miguel Bieger sieht Fitnesscenter nur noch von innen,
wenn er einen Malerauftrag hat.
Ein paar Zwiebeln wären gut.
Ist gut? - Mhm.
Soll ich alle Tomaten reintun? Nicht, oder?- Ja, ja.
Wirklich?
Für einen ehemaligen Schweizer Meister im Bodybuilding: erstaunlich.
Früher haben Sie das Essen noch abgewogen. Machen Sie das noch?
Nein.
Gar nicht mehr, gar nicht mehr.
Wir haben nicht mal eine Waage. - Stimmt.
Das kommt noch hinzu.
Wir essen querfeldein.
Heisst das nicht quer durchs Beet?
Du weisst, was ich meine.
Vor fünf Jahren ging's in Biegers Küche anders zu und her.
Das sind 120 g Haferflocken.
Whei Proteine.
Ich gebe noch ein paar Heidelbeeren dazu.
Durch das Proteinpulver, Vanille und die Beeren
gibt das einen guten Geschmack.
Das oberste Ziel ist einfach, kein Fett ansetzen?
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Dann nehme ich noch Zinktabletten,
Fettsäure Omega 3 ist auch sehr wichtig.
Anstatt sonstige Fette zu essen.
Das sind gesunde Fette, die man braucht.
BCA, Aminosäuren, Vitamintabletten.
All die Proteine.
Das war einmal.
Nein, ich glaube, es hat keine Proteine mehr.
Doch, du hast noch so alte irgendwo. - Ich glaube, hier. Ja.
Hier hinten habe ich noch.
Das ist alles, was ich noch habe.
Wahrscheinlich schon längst abgelaufen.
Oh! 7.3.2018.
Warum nicht wegwerfen? - Das frage ich mich auch.
Also können wir es auch gleich wegleeren.
Wie einer ...
Wie ein Abhängiger, der seine Drogen ...
... vernichtet.
Das ist viel Geld, das man lange immer ausgegeben hat,
das im Endeffekt ...
Wenn man mal einen Monat pausiert,
verliert man sowieso die Hälfte der Muskeln.
Früher hatten wir überall in der Küche Proteine,
jetzt haben wir hier ein Shisha-Fach.
Einst übergewichtig, dann Bodybuilder -
Bieger hat mit seinem Körper schon einiges durchgemacht.
Und dabei auch etwas gelernt.
Ich finde,
man muss sich auf einer gesunden Basis selbst schön finden.
Genau.
Sodass man auch mit sich leben kann.
"Reporter Spezial" - wir gehen der Frage nach:
Was tun wir eigentlich alles für unsere Schönheit, unser Aussehen?
Und macht es uns am Schluss auch wirklich glücklicher?
Es ist erstaunlich: Von den Teenagern in der Schweiz,
im Alter von ca. 12-16, sagen schon zwei Drittel,
sie seien entweder zu dick oder zu dünn.
Eigentlich finden sie schon,
sie müssten irgendetwas tun für ihr Aussehen.
Ich bin hier in der Maske des Schweizer Fernsehens.
Hier wird wahrscheinlich am meisten übers Aussehen gesprochen.
Und das hier hinten ist Divina Hunziker,
sie arbeitet seit knapp zehn Jahren hier.
Divina, du hast zum Thema Aussehen sehr viel zu sagen.
Damit wir uns richtig unterhalten können,
müsstest du die Maske ausziehen und wir mehr Distanz einnehmen.
Gut, machen wir. - Okay, gut.
Divina Hunziker hat für ihr Schönheitsideal
beinahe ihre Gesundheit ruiniert.
Eine Folge davon ist, dass sie mo- mentan nicht schwanger werden könnte.
Was hast du in den letzten Jahren alles getan,
um z.B. deinen Körper zu formen? - Sehr viel trainiert.
Das hat damit angefangen, um fit zu werden.
Vor ca. neun Jahren habe ich mit Triathlon angefangen.
Dort hinein habe ich meine ganze Perfektion gelegt,
um in den Disziplinen stark zu werden.
Als ich das geschafft hatte und irgendwann keine Lust mehr hatte,
immer Ausdauer zu machen, habe ich in den Kraftsport gewechselt.
Das war ein fliessender Übergang.
Plötzlich fand ich Gefallen daran, ins Aussehen einzugreifen.
Man kann dort eine Schraube anziehen und etwas perfektionieren.
Wie geht das vor sich?
Am Anfang kam ich in Kontakt mit zwei Bodybuilderinnen,
die ich damals geschminkt und frisiert habe,
damit sie auf die Bühne konnten.
Ich war ganz interessiert,
wie sie es geschafft haben, dieses Heruntergeschreddertsein.
Dieses was? - Heruntergeschreddertsein.
Das ist, wenn man den Körper so stark hinunterdefiniert,
dass man jegliche Muskelfasern sieht, weil es wirklich trocken ist.
Sie haben mir das erklärt und es hat mich wahnsinnig interessiert.
Ich habe viel darüber nachgelesen.
Dann habe ich selbst damit angefangen.
Einfach für mich, nicht mit dem Ziel, auf die Bühne zu gehen.
Ich wollte das Limit ...
Ich wollte spüren, wohin ich meinen Körper treiben kann.
Wie wolltest du sein?
Was war dein Ideal der perfekten Divina?
Es gab in dem Sinn nicht mal ein fertiges Bild.
Klar, ich wollte muskulös und drahtig sein,
ich wollte, dass man die Muskelfasern sieht,
wie z.B. bei den beiden Bodybuilderinnen.
Aber ich wollte eher schauen,
wie tief ich meinen Fettwert hinunterbringe.
Und zwar aus eigener Kraft, ohne Hilfsmittel.
Denn im Bodybuilding ist bekannt,
dass die meisten mit Zusatzstoffen arbeiten
und es so erreichen.
Mein Ziel war, es auf natürlichem Weg zu erreichen,
das absolute Maximum.
Es war wirklich ein absolut niedriger Fettanteil
und viel Muskelmasse.
Und wie weit bist du gekommen? - Sehr weit.
Ich würde sagen, ich war wirklich bühnenreif.
Ich hätte auf eine Bühne gehen können.
D.h.? - Bei einem Bodybuilding-Contest.
Hast du Bilder? - Ja, ich habe Bilder.
So hat das ausgesehen? - Ja.
Es war wirklich ziemlich hinunterdefiniert.
Wenn du die Bilder jetzt anschaust - findest du sie schön?
Nein, wenn ich jetzt zurückschaue, muss ich tatsächlich sagen:
Nein, es ist wirklich nicht das,
was ich damals im Spiegel gesehen habe.
Ich habe ich anders gesehen. Ich dachte, da geht noch mehr.
Wenn ich die Bilder jetzt anschaue, habe ich das Gefühl: Nein!
Es war wirklich so viel zu viel.
Deshalb bin ich froh, dass ich mich entschieden habe,
den Weg wieder zurückzugehen.
Obwohl es sehr schwierig ist, umzustellen.
Wann kam der Moment, in dem du gemerkt hast: "Das ist zu viel"?
Indem mein Körper es mir gezeigt hat.
Die Periode blieb aus.
Am Anfang dachte ich noch, das sei ein schöner Nebeneffekt.
"Dann habe ich sie halt nicht, die kommt dann schon wieder."
Aber die Periode kam und kam nicht.
Nach einem Jahr war sie immer noch nicht da.
Dazu bekam ich Verdauungsbeschwerden, Haarausfall.
Der Körper hat wirklich relativ krass zu zeigen versucht:
"Hey, das geht zu weit."
Und Überlastungen wie beidseitige Baker-Zysten in den Knien.
Ich habe auch das Patellaspitzensyndrom beim Knie,
Schleimbeutelentzündungen in den Hüften.
Alles kleine Dinge, die sich dann summiert haben.
Und irgendwann musste ich sagen: Jetzt ist wohl der Moment gekommen,
um auf die Gesundheit zu achten und umzukehren.
Ich stelle mir vor:
Wenn man so viel investiert hat in einen "perfekten Körper",
muss es extrem schwierig sein, zu sagen: "Jetzt höre ich auf."
Das ist wirklich wahnsinnig schwierig - immer noch.
Dieses Bild ist so eingebrannt im Kopf.
Dieses loszulassen, in den Spiegel zu schauen und zu merken:
"Oh Gott, jetzt sieht man das Sixpack nicht mehr so extrem,
jetzt ist mehr Wasser da, vielleicht mehr Fett."
Man verändert sich allgemein wieder.
Und es ist sehr schwierig, sich dann nicht zu sagen:
"Ich halte mich wieder strikt an meine Kalorien und mache Diät."
Man muss nach Plan gehen und hoffen, dass sich alles wieder normalisiert,
auch mit den Hormonen.
Das ist dann hoffentlich der Preis, den ich bekomme.
Schaffst du das? - Ich hoffe es!
Ich hoffe es ganz stark.
Ich arbeite wirklich daran, immer mehr und mehr davon wegzukommen,
weniger verbissen zu sein.
Und mein Körper braucht es tatsächlich.
Denn es sind jetzt anderthalb Jahre, die ich keine Periode habe.
Obwohl ich mehr esse, obwohl ich weniger Sport mache.
Ich glaube, deshalb braucht es extremere Massnahmen,
damit der Körper checkt, dass er wieder safe ist
und alles wieder passieren kann, wie es sollte.
Deshalb muss ich unbedingt erreichen,
viel weniger Sport zu machen.
Wie viele Menschen wie dich gibt es wohl, die fürs Aussehen
eigentlich totalen Raubbau betreiben, vielleicht auch an der Gesundheit?
Viele. Ich glaube, extrem viele.
Und ich glaube, es ist auch extrem wichtig,
über solche Themen zu reden und auch anzusprechen,
welche Gefahren es mit sich bringt.
Denn v.a. die Jungen, die du vorhin erwähnt hast ...
Teenager. - Sie teilen sich schon ein, sagen:
"Nein, ich bin zu dick, ich wollte etwas tun."
Genau ihnen müsste man wirklich sagen, wie gefährlich es ist.
Man sollte lieber normal bleiben, in einem guten Mittelmass,
und nicht nach den ganzen Instagrammern streben
und den ganzen Leuten, die sich auf Social Media zeigen.
Mit dem perfekten Schuss, nachdem sie sich entwässert haben.
Sie tun sehr vieles
und das Bearbeiten ist nicht zu vergessen.
Und die Leute haben das Gefühl, wenn man das anschaut,
es sei normal, die Realität.
So müsse man aussehen. - Und das ist es absolut nicht.
Im Beitrag hat jemand gesagt,
seit er nicht mehr die ganze Zeit etwas mache,
sei er eigentlich glücklicher.
Kannst du das nachvollziehen? - Ein Stück weit, ja.
Man müsste es in einem guten Mittelmass machen können,
dann wäre man am glücklichsten.
An welchem Punkt bist du denn jetzt?
Ich würde sagen, an einem guten Punkt, auf dem Weg der Besserung.
Ich habe aufgehört zu tracken, habe etwas Kontrolle abgegeben.
Also nicht mehr abmessen, was du alles isst.
Nicht mehr alles abwägen und das ganze Essen unter Kontrolle haben.
Die habe ich langsam abgegeben.
Und es fühlt sich langsam auch wirklich gut an.
Ich habe mein Trainingspensum reduziert,
ich schaue, dass ich drei- bis viermal pro Woche trainiere,
nicht mehr fünf- bis siebenmal.
Deshalb glaube ich, auf dem guten Weg der Besserung.
Aber noch nicht dort, wo du hinmöchtest?
Nein, noch nicht ganz. Aber das kommt.
Man kann beim Körper sehr viel beeinflussen,
du hast es selbst erlebt.
Andere Dinge passieren uns allen, z.B. das Älterwerden.
Kein Wunder, geben wir viel Geld aus,
um die Spuren zu tilgen, um "jünger" auszusehen.
Vom Haarefärben über Antifaltencreme
bis zu vielen schönheitschirurgischen Eingriffen.
Ist Schönheit wirklich das Privileg der Jugend?
Wir lernen jetzt eine Frau kennen, die das total anders sieht,
und sie ist 70.
Siehst du den Unterschied?
Wenn man älter ist, hat man schon so vieles gesehen.
Man ist doch reif.
Man ist ja nicht nur schön, wenn man jung ist,
sondern auch, wenn man reifer wird.
Ich bin jetzt so, wie ich bin.
Ob ich früher schöner war, ob ich mich schöner gefühlt habe?
Nein, das kann ich so nicht sagen.
Ich fühlte mich immer wohl, so, wie ich bin.
Carmen Meier, Jahrgang 1951,
bei einem Fotoshooting in Zürich.
Genau.
So. Fühlst du dich wohl? - Ja, sehr.
Ja? - Sehr.
Ich gehe nie ohne meine roten Lippen aus dem Haus.
So fühle ich mich gepflegt.
Nein, ich gehe nicht ...
Ohne Lippenstift gehe ich nicht einmal zum Briefkasten.
Auch zu Hause trage ich immer als erstes Lippenstift auf.
Heute haben wir ein sehr reduziertes Outfit, verschiedene Looks.
Seit sie sich erinnern kann,
habe Aussehen und Styling eine Wichtigkeit in ihrem Leben.
Die Mutter, eine Italienerin,
habe das schönste Bimbi aus ihr machen wollen.
Aber schon als Kleine habe sie nicht alles akzeptiert.
Ich erinnere mich daran,
dass mir meine Tante in Italien ein paar Schuhe gekauft hat.
Dann hat sie mir die Schuhe an- gezogen und ich erinnere mich genau,
wie ich gesagt habe: "No, no, no!"
"Weisse Schuhe ziehe ich gar nicht erst an."
Unten weiss ist Scheiss. Das wusste ich damals bereits.
Ich wollte das nicht.
Die Tante war so enttäuscht,
weil sie mir die Schuhe auf dem Dorfmarkt gekauft hatte,
und mir damit einen Gefallen machen wollte.
Doch ich habe sie nie getragen.
Mit 20 war sie Kauffrau. Dann Kosmetikerin mit eigenem Geschäft.
Mit 55 war wurde sie in den Bündner Bergen entdeckt ― als Model.
Seither ist sie als sog. Grey Model international gefragt.
London, Bologna, Zürich.
In der Branche spricht man von Body diversitiy.
Ich würde eigentlich gerne mehr Models wie Carmen shooten.
Nicht nur aufgrund des Alters,
sondern allgemein Models verschiedener Herkunft,
verschiedener Hautfarben, verschiedener Kleidergrössen.
Ich fände es schön, wenn es das öfter geben würde.
In der Branche ist der Umstieg eigentlich sichtbar.
Doch in der Schweiz ist es noch nicht so angekommen.
Ich denke, es kommt. Das finde ich begrüssenswert.
Mega cool!
Bei den Proportionen werden allerdings keine Kompromisse gemacht.
Die müssen stimmen.
Ja, Schönheit macht glücklich.
Denn man kann doch Schönheit mit allen Sinnen erfassen.
Es macht einen doch glücklich, wenn man ein schönes Bild sieht,
schöne Architektur, einen schönen Raum,
wenn man an einem schönen Ort ist.
Wenn man etwas Schönes anziehen kann, einen schönen Schmuck.
Oder wenn man eine schöne Begebenheit hat.
Man kann doch Schönheit mit allen Sinnen wahrnehmen.
Deshalb ist das für mich sogar fast zentral wichtig.
Jetzt sind wir bei Carmen Meier zu Hause.
Die beiden anderen am Tisch haben wir bereits kennengelernt.
Carmen Meier wurde als Model entdeckt,
läuft heute auf grossen Laufstegen in den italienischen Modemetropolen,
wohnt wunderschön am Zürichsee in einem tollen Haus,
sieht aus, wie sie aussieht.
Deine Mitmenschen müssen dich beneiden, oder nicht?
Das habe ich jetzt alles.
Aber das ist mir ja nicht wie ein gebratenes Hähnchen
in den Mund gefallen.
Ich habe sehr, sehr, sehr viel dafür gearbeitet.
Das bekam ich nicht einfach so.
Jetzt bin ich hier, mir geht es gut und ich finde es schön.
Es ist auch nicht selbstverständlich.
Aber ich wäre auch die genau gleiche Carmen,
wenn ich an einem ganz anderen Ort wohnen würde.
Irgendwo abseits.
Darauf kommt es nicht an. Es kommt nur auf einen selbst an.
Woher hast du denn dein Selbstbewusstsein?
So wie ich das spüre, hast du dich immer gut gefühlt, wie du bist.
Hattest du einfach Glück, dass du gut aussiehst?
Ich weiss nicht, ob weisse Haare schön sind. Mir ist es egal.
Man kann doch auch mit weissen Haaren eine tolle Frisur machen.
Man kann doch einfach entspannt sich selbst sein.
Das zählt aus meiner Sicht.
Zina, wie ist das bei dir?
Carmen sagte gerade, sie sei immer im Reinen mit sich selbst gewesen.
Bekommt man das einfach geschenkt?
Das ist sehr schwierig.
Ich denke, wenn man gutes Aussehen geschenkt bekommt -
von den Genen, von der Natur, von Gott,
wie auch immer man das benennen möchte -
glaube ich, dass es einem leichter fällt,
an sich selbst zu arbeiten, sich zu entwickeln.
Man hat es dann gewissermassen immer etwas einfacher.
Alexandra Baumann, was löst Carmen in dir aus?
Sie ist natürlich eine sehr elegante Erscheinung.
Ich kenne sie noch nicht lange, aber meine Wahrnehmung ist,
dass es so effortless ist.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass du sehr natürlich bist.
Du bist eine natürlich elegante Erscheinung.
Ich finde Neid immer ein etwas schwieriges Wort.
Ich möchte nicht von Neid sprechen,
aber in mir wird ein Gefühl ausgelöst,
dass ich manchmal - nicht immer - auch gerne etwas mehr so wäre.
Ich denke, diese Zufriedenheit ...
Du musst selbst stark sein.
Du musst doch nicht auf das hören, was andere sagen.
Du musst doch nicht so sein, wie es andere von dir wollen.
Du musst so sein, wie du dich wohl fühlst.
Wenn du dich wohl fühlst, bist du ein glücklicher Mensch -
egal, wie du aussiehst.
Du musst nicht dich selbst kritisieren.
Sei doch dankbar. - Es ist nicht immer so...
Entschuldige die Unterbrechung.
Man kritisiert sich nicht in erster Linie selbst.
Ich finde, es wird einem so vorgelebt oder vom Umfeld gesagt:
"Was machst du da? Du kommst mir zu nahe. Du bist zu dick."
Nein, also ... - Das denke ich.
Es ist schon schön, wenn man sich selbst sein kann.
Doch man wird auch von aussen geformt.
Man wird leider vom Umfeld ein Stück weit definiert und beeinflusst.
Und das ist nicht einfach.
Deshalb kannst du so hart sagen: "sei doch du selbst". Das ist gut.
Es ist also einfach, selbstbewusst zu sein,
wenn man wie Carmen aussieht? - Ja.
Du kannst doch nicht das gleiche Selbstbewusstsein entwickeln,
wenn dir immer nur gesagt wird, dass du nicht okay bist,
wie wenn du in irgendeine Norm passt.
Ich muss mir das jetzt erst ...
Natürlich bin ich jetzt mit 41 eine erwachsene Frau,
aber ich erschaffe mir jetzt das Selbstbewusstsein.
Hätten wir das Gespräch vor einigen Jahren geführt,
hätte ich mich anders dazu geäussert.
Ich hätte auch nie jemandem wie dir widersprochen.
Aber ich glaube, du kannst nicht nachvollziehen,
wie ich das Leben wahrnehme.
Im Fitnesscenter wurde mir schon gesagt:
"So etwas Ekelhaftes will ich doch hier nicht sehen."
Weshalb gehst du ins Fitnesscenter?
Arbeite doch zu Hause an dir selbst, wenn du dich gepeinigt fühlst.
Findest du es okay, dass ich nicht ins Fitnesscenter gehen kann?
Weshalb sollten sich die Dicken verstecken?
Nein, weil sie dich plagen. Du brauchst dich nicht zu verstecken.
Aber du musst dich dem nicht aussetzen.
Auch wenn ich im Wald laufen gehe, setze ich mich dem aus.
Im Wald hat mir kürzlich jemand gesagt:
"Bewege den dicken Po, dann wird er vielleicht etwas kleiner."
Im Wald, weisst du.
Das ist ja schrecklich. - Aber das kannst du nicht ...
Du kennst das gar nicht. - Nein.
Ich kenne das nicht. Ich würde wohl nicht ins Fitnesscenter gehen.
Dann muss man sich aber zu Hause verstecken.
Nein, darum geht es doch nicht.
Mir braucht doch niemand beim trainieren zuzuschauen.
Das kann ich doch zu Hause machen.
Ehrlich gesagt mache ich mir eher Gedanken darüber,
dass wir Menschen jemandem wie Alexandra so etwas sagen.
Du dir nicht auch? - Doch, sicher.
Aber ich bin nicht wie diese Menschen. Ich würde das nie tun.
Dich überrascht das Verhalten der Menschen.
Ja, ich finde das grässlich.
Ja. - Nein, nein.
Das nehme ich aus all diesen Gesprächen mit:
Nicht unsere Körper, Gesichter oder Kleidergrössen sind das Problem.
Es ist unser Umgang mit Menschen,
die auf eine Art anders sind oder aussehen.
Sich nicht mehr auf die Oberfläche zu fixieren
macht niemanden schöner, aber viele glücklicher.